حسنًا ، هذه القصة التالية مخيفة أن
رجلًا في منطقة هيوستن أصبح حراً بالفعل
بعد أن تم اتهامه باختطاف
واعتداء امرأة قابلها على
تطبيق المواعدة Bumble ، تقول المرأة البالغة من العمر 21 عامًا
إن زاكاري كينت ميلز
احتجزها أسيرة بدون  الطعام أو الماء لمدة خمسة
أيام ثم ضربها عندما حاولت
الهروب من سي إن إن المراسل الوطني الكبير
إد لافينديرا يتابع هذه
التطورات ، فماذا وماذا
نتعلم من وثائق المحكمة
هذه هي المستندات التي تم تقديمها
في اعتقال 21  زاكاري كينت ميلز ، البالغ من العمر عامًا
، واستنادًا إلى المقابلات
التي أجراها المحققون مع
الضحية في هذه القضية حيث تزعم
أنها في ليلة عيد الميلاد في 24 ديسمبر ، اتصلت
بـ uh Mills على تطبيق المواعدة
Bumble وأنه جاء من
شقتها وأخذها وأخذها
عادوا إلى شقته وهذا هو المكان
الذي حاول على الفور ، وفقًا لوثائق المحكمة ،
الانخراط في
الجماع الجنسي ، أخبرت الضحية
المحققين أنه  دمجت
التقدم وبعد ذلك بدأت المطاحن
بالاعتداء عليها جسديًا
بلكمها وصفعها وحتى في مرحلة ما باستخدام
مفك البراغي لإلحاق
أضرار بالمرأة ، كما كشفت وثائق المحكمة
أن المرأة عثر
عليها بكدمات في العيون.
بالإضافة إلى جروح في رقبتها وحنجرها
على الرغم من كل هذا بعد خمسة أيام ،
قررت ميلز وفقًا لوثائق المحكمة مغادرة شقته
الحكومية والذهاب لرؤية والده ،
وذلك عندما تمكنت المرأة من
الفرار وعلى الرغم من كل هذا
يقول محامي ميلز إنه لا
ينبغي لأحد أن يتسرع في الحكم في هذه القضية
بألا يكون غير حساس
للشاهد المشتكي على الإطلاق أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل أو
لأي شخص قد يكون قد مر بالفعل
بهذه الأحداث الصادمة ولكن
أعتقد أنه من المهم أيضًا معرفة أن
هناك  وجهان لهذه القصة
يفترض أن موكلي بريء كما هو الحال مع
الثبات من خلال الدستور والإجراءات
القانونية
الآن كما ذكرت أن جيم ميلز خارج على
السند i  كان سندات 50000 هناك بعض
الشروط أه في هذا الإفراج ، لا
يُسمح له بالدخول إلى مسافة 200 قدم من
مكان عمل الضحية أو الذهاب إلى المدرسة
، وعليه مراقبة حظر تجول لمدة 24 ساعة في
المنزل كما أنه ليس كذلك
من المتوقع أن يعود إلى المحكمة حتى
أوائل مارس